e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando fue la última vez que en pandemia
hicieron una actividad en un espacio
público en una plaza en un parque
recuerdan qué elementos había
había mantas había equipos de mate
habían llevado sus bicicletas
sin duda la pandemia nos invitó a
cambiar por completo el modo en que
habitamos el mundo nuestros hogares los
espacios privados se transformaron en
una especie de salón de usos múltiples
en el que todos los integrantes del
hogar hacemos en simultáneo distintas
actividades y muchas veces compartimos
no solo los espacios físicos sino
también los dispositivos
al mismo momento en que esto sucede
porque mudamos distintas actividades que
hacíamos en el mundo público al mundo
privado también hay un movimiento un
poquito en sentido inverso desde adentro
hacia afuera hay un montón de
actividades que antes de la pandemia
hacíamos en los espacios privados y que
a partir del cobi comenzamos a hacer o
mudamos al espacio público
una reunión vecinal un encuentro con
amigos una reunión de consorcio hasta un
cumpleaños cuando queremos ver a alguien
en un cumpleaños lo hacemos en un
espacio al aire libre en un espacio
público
y esto no implica únicamente cambiar de
escenario no es que dejamos de cortar la
torta en el comedor de nuestras casas y
mudamos esto al espacio público
si pensáramos la vida en comunidad como
una gran obra de teatro lo que está
cambiando no es únicamente el escenario
están cambiando también los personajes
es decir los roles sociales que los
ciudadanos y las ciudadanas asumimos en
esa obra y si está cambiando el
escenario y están cambiando los
personajes también podemos pensar que
está cambiando el argumento y la trama
de esa obra
la pandemia en este sentido nos está
permitiendo recuperar revalorizar los
espacios públicos
y habló de recuperar porque si hacemos
un poquito de historia y vamos a hacer
30 o 40 años atrás era bastante habitual
por ejemplo que el plan del del fin de
semana pasa sé eminentemente por hacer
alguna actividad en un espacio público
como en esta foto que estamos viendo por
ejemplo
hay una pareja dos personas de espaldas
en costanera norte viendo como
despegaban los aviones esta foto es de
1968 y es bastante representativa
respecto de cómo se transitaba el ocio y
la recreación por esas décadas por esos
años que en general pasaba centralmente
por la vida en comunidad por armar
vínculos con otros en espacios públicos
si vamos a la década del 80
por ejemplo hay distintas experiencias
donde se han celebrado cumpleaños en
espacios públicos en las plazas en los
parques y la postal era bien interesante
porque se armaba un escenario particular
para esto en principio había en general
guirnaldas que cruzaban de árbol a árbol
había también mesitas con manteles que
si era primavera y había este el viento
típico de la primavera había que amarrar
esos manteles había también vasitos a
veces se llevaban juegos como por
ejemplo el elástico la soga la pelota
y había también personajes centrales más
allá de el cumpleañero o la cumpleañera
estaban las madres estaba la madre de
quien cumplía años y en general se
armaba como una especie de comité de
apoyo logístico y moral no con otras
madres que también acompañaban y estaban
al cuidado de esos niños y de esas niñas
en los años 90 esto empieza a cambiar y
empieza a ver una especie de movimiento
o de tendencia hacia la privacidad hacia
el mundo de lo privado
qué pasó
o distintos cambios sociales culturales
urbanísticos económicos pero apareció un
elemento central que tiene que ver con
la tecnología y que tiene que ver
particularmente con internet
esto cambió radicalmente el modo de ser
de estar de percibir
y de conocer el mundo
no necesitábamos salir al mundo exterior
de manera permanente porque había
experiencias que las podíamos atravesar
si teníamos una computadora con acceso a
internet
territorio y escritorio empezaron a ser
dos canales para conocer el mundo porque
hasta antes de la aparición de internet
nuestros vínculos pasaban esencialmente
por nuestra localidad geográfica se
ajustaban a nuestro barrio a nuestra
comunidad el acceso a internet nos
permitió ampliar horizontes y pudimos
empezar a identificarnos oa potenciar
este proceso de identificación
con movimientos sociales deportivos
artísticos con personas que quizás
estaban a un océano de distancia
entonces internet
nos permitió empezar a vivir estas
experiencias en el mundo privado
aprendimos a hacer una compra pudimos
tomar una clase trabajar analizar nos
enviar un regalo
tenemos la sensación entonces que de
repente con la pandemia dejamos de
circular o de transitar por espacios
públicos
y nos recluimos o empezamos a atravesar
esas experiencias en el mundo de lo
privado
la pandemia en este sentido nos está
permitiendo recuperar revalorizar los
espacios públicos
podemos pensar que estos espacios
públicos se transforman en dispositivos
en espacios para la transformación
social
para el cambio y también se transforman
en espacios para la promoción de salud
de salud integral porque siempre es con
otros con una comunidad
esto lo podemos ver en por lo menos
cinco aspectos
en primer lugar evitar estos espacios
públicos nos permiten ser protagonistas
del cambio social que queremos
porque en este territorio en estos
parques en estas plazas
circulan valores
como la solidaridad
el compromiso social
la colaboración la cooperación el
respeto
el cuidado de sí el cuidado de otros
y el cuidado del planeta
este verano estaba haciendo bici en el
parque en una tarde calurosa de enero
y observé tres adolescentes que estaban
depositando las botellas plásticas en
los puntos verdes de reciclado
en ese momento sentí cierto calor que
pude identificar no tenía que ver con el
calor de una típica tarde de enero sino
con un calor que quizás había sentido
hace muchos años en primer año del
secundario cuando había armado
prolijamente en ese momento creía que
era prolijamente hoy evidentemente no un
machete y lo había pegado en la falda no
de la pollera el machete era
particularmente de la tabla periódica y
me engancharon
esa vergüenza que yo sentí cuando
alguien me vio haciendo algo que no
debía fue la misma vergüenza que sentí
hacen asia ante esos tres adolescentes
ante tres adolescentes que me estaban
regalando una oportunidad preciosa de
aprender a cuidar el planeta
hoy sin darme cuenta tal vez le hago
pasar ese calor a otros porque cuando
voy a tomar algo con alguien y estamos
afuera en la mesita yo levanto las manos
y le pregunto al hermoso a la moza si
reciclan porque si no reciclan yo me
llevo las botellas las cargo en el
canasto de mi bici y las depositó en el
punto verde porque hoy es a causa de
esos adolescentes en mi propia causa
en segundo lugar
estar en estos espacios públicos nos
permite ejercer una ciudadanía activa
porque no importa si vos te mudaste al
barrio hace dos meses no importa si yo
vivo en este barrio hace cinco años si
ella es propietaria si él es inquilino
todas las voces tienen el mismo valor
todas
y todas esas voces pueden opinar y
decidir conjuntamente por ejemplo qué
hacemos con la canchita del barrio
y esto también invita a otros a cuidar
ese barrio y a cuidar esos espacios
públicos que muchas veces los vemos como
ajenos pero nos pertenecen son nuestros
porque si esa es tu banco
6 recibiste la mejor noticia de tu vida
si esa es tu esquina si esta fue la
última vez que hablaste por teléfono con
tu mamá o que te enviaron una foto de tu
sobrino si esa es la senda por la que
tus hijos han andar en bicicleta todos
los días
vas a tener ganas de cuidarlo
y vas a tener ganas de invitar a otros a
que lo cuiden y vas a tener ganas de
colaborar con lo que tengas con lo que
sepas hacer con tus manos
aunque más no sea con un plato de comida
caliente
para las personas que no tienen hogar y
que hacen de esa plaza su casa
en tercer lugar
estar y recorrer estos espacios públicos
nos permiten recuperar el saber popular
y la memoria colectiva
ser popular es un saber que es para zito
que se transmite generalmente desde la
oralidad
no podemos acceder a este saber popular
por más que seamos parte del 85% de la
población mundial que accede a la
lectoescritura es un saber que se
captura estando ahí en el territorio en
la cancha no en la tribuna
porque ese señor que vio en el parque a
la chica ajustando el pedal de la bici y
le dijo piba necesitas una llave
francesa si no se te va a salir
o esa señora que le contaba a sus nietos
y a los amigos de sus nietos como cuando
ella era joven se cruzaba a los
jugadores de platense ya sus familias
recorriendo el parque saavedra no van a
escribir un paper no producen un saber
científico portan y producen un saber
popular que para circular necesita
ciertas condiciones que es el territorio
esto nos permite también
historizar nos
historizar nos y proyectarnos cumplen
para una comunidad la misma función
organizar la experiencia
como vamos a entender hacia dónde vamos
como comunidad cómo vamos a entender qué
proyecto de comunidad queremos si no
entendemos desde dónde venimos
cuál es nuestra historia
en cuarto lugar estar en estos espacios
públicos nos permite ejercer una ética
de cuidado y una ética de la
responsabilidad
estoy segura todos en general circulamos
por la calle y vemos personas con el
barbijo mal colocado
en la pera o directamente sin barbijo
y eso existe y es una realidad
al mismo tiempo en que eso sucede
hay decenas me animaría a decir quizás
centenares de personas ejerciendo una
ética de cuidado hacia otros hay un
ejercicio que es muy gratificante los
invito y las invito si un fin de semana
circulan por los alrededores de una
plaza o de un parque y es contemplar
qué pasa en los edificios y en las casas
aledañas seguramente se van a encontrar
con alguien que toma su reposera su
manda su equipo de mate y va a la plaza
a encontrarse con alguien son personas
que viven ahí a tres cuadras a 4 al 10
de ese parque pueden reunirse en un
espacio cerrado y privado y sin embargo
deciden hacerlo en un espacio público
porque comprenden la importancia de
encontrarse con otros en un espacio
público y al aire libre y esto es una
ética de cuidado primero hacia sí mismos
porque yo no le puedo dar a otro lo que
no me puedan a mí misma primero hacia sí
mismos y luego hacia esos otros que
componen la comunidad
en quinto y último lugar
recorrer estos espacios públicos estar
ahí sentirlos nos permite armar y
reforzar vínculos vecinales
todos los que crecimos en un barrio en
una comunidad de vínculos vecinales
fuertes
entendimos que casi nuestra vida
cotidiana nunca se hubiera podido
desarrollar sin el soporte de los
vecinos sin el vecino que nos avisa que
se escapó el perro si no el vecino que
nos deja la llave debajo de la maceta
sin el vecino que nos arropó nos cuidó y
nos llevó a la escuela cuando nuestros
padres no podían hacerlo sin esa vecina
que nos recibe el pedido del
supermercado
esto también nos permite aprender
aprender de esos vínculos
intergeneracionales como por ejemplo
doña herminia que estaba en el parque
con su marido tomando sol y vio a una
pareja que estaba intentando sin éxito
dormir un bebito el bebito lloraba
lloraba y lloraba no era muy difícil
pensar que la situación estaba
complicada hacía bastante tiempo
bastante rato doña herminia miró se
levantó y tomó posición
y le dijo a la chica
en hacerle zancadas
como zancadas
arminda
lo mostraba imagínense que este es el
bebito hacia abajo y hacia arriba hacia
abajo y hacia arriba era casi para los
que estábamos viendo la escena como una
clase de localizada
aquí no saben qué pasó
la respuesta no los sorprenderá por
supuesto el bebito se durmió
con herminda no hubiera podido desplegar
ese saber no lo hubiese podido regalar
esa oportunidad de conocimiento a esta
pareja si no hubiese existido el marco
de un vínculo vecinal de un vínculo que
se dio en el territorio doña herlinda
como el señor que le enseñó a la chica
ajustar el pedal de la bici tienen un
saber
y si bien no es un saber científico
lograron mostrar con evidencia concreta
que saber funciona
qué es un saber instrumental
entonces
estamos ante una oportunidad
preciada preciosa
y también histórica
de recuperar estos espacios públicos no
solo los espacios sino también la red
social y vincular
que hace décadas viene deshilachándose
viene desgajándose
no solo tenemos la oportunidad sino que
también tenemos las herramientas los
recursos
tenemos nuestro cuerpo
tenemos nuestras manos
para ir hilando
para ir armando este tejido
un tejido
que nos va a invitar
bailar a tensar ajustar
a lugar
y este tejido no es individual
es un telar
es un telar que es colectivo
es hoy
es acá
es ahora
sos vos
soy yo
somos colectivamente grupalmente
y comunitariamente
la propuesta queda planteada
salgamos del agujero interior
y recuperemos la posibilidad de habitar
los espacios públicos
porque nos pertenecen
porque son nuestros
porque nunca dejaron de serlo
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]